nur eine vermutung aber ich behaupte
momentan werden die grünen echt dankbar
wenn boris palmer mal wieder irgendetwas
über fußballer genitalien posten würde
ja als ablenkung von der sache mit der
box nebeneinkünften es geht wissen sie
um sonderzahlungen der partei vor allem
geht es um weihnachtsgeld rund 25.000
euro hat annalena baerbock mit
mehrjähriger verspätung beim bundestag
nachgemeldet klarer fall von scheitern
an den eigenen moralischen ansprüchen
und eine top gelegenheit für angemessen
zerknirschte selbstkritik ich habe ich
natürlich selbst über meinen fehler
tierisch geärgert darüber ärgere ich
mich glaube ich am meisten selbst dass
ich mich tierisch über den fehler ärgere
natürlich ärgere ich mich selbst sehr
darüber natürlich habe ich mich selber
tierisch darüber aber sie haben ja das
weihnachts und ich habe nicht ihre
spiele
ach komm 25.000 türken die können ja
schonmal durchrutschen
es sind zwei monate miete in münchen wo
ich plötzlich finden alle möglichen
politiker noch geld das sie nicht
angegeben haben
berbalk cem özdemir oder karl lauterbach
hat in der schublade mit seinen alten
fliegen auch noch ein paar
vortragshonoraren entdeckt aber klar bei
einer kanzlerkandidatin tut's mehr weh
ist ja logisch und es ist auch erlaubt
durchaus erlaubt zu fragen für welche
mehrbelastung krieg der vorstand der
grünen bitten corona zulage sie merken
die schonzeit für annalena baerbock ist
vorbei sogar bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen wo man lange viel
zu nett war der burg redet viel bekommt
auch die zeit dafür armin laschet
kanzlerkandidat der union ist als
zugeschaltete gast nicht nur optisch im
nachteil
optisch im nachteil er sieht aus wie
armin laschet was soll er denn machen
als armin laschet
fakt ist gerade den grünen die ständig
von transparenz reden darf so ein fehler
nicht passiert punkt und ich glaube
keiner ärgert sich mehr darüber als
annalena baerbock
aber wie sieht es denn insgesamt aus mit
den bezahlten nebeneinkünften unserer
politiker zwei drittel der abgeordneten
in berlin haben gar keine
das heißt die leben tatsächlich
von ihren diäten keine ahnung wie das
geht aber das andere drittel gleicht es
mehr als aus hier dass nebeneinkünfte
ranking unserer parteien die union als
größte fraktion auch der größte
verdiener jeder dritte von denen
verdient sich was dazu bei der fdp sogar
über die hälfte und die grünen am ihren
sich mit 120000 euro alle zusammen in
einer wahlperiode noch hinter den linken
jedoch gar nicht gut muss man dazu sagen
das sind brutto einkünfte brutto
einkünfte von zum teil sehr
erfolgreichen anwälten und landwirten
jetzt kann man fragen warum haben so
viele abgeordnete überhaupt zeit für
andere tätigkeiten
man kann aber auch argumentieren die
sind halt fleißig im gegensatz zu andern
liebe grüne wir müssen mal reden nur
122000 euro nebeneinkünfte ist das euer
ernst
die anderen parteien lachen möchte aus
122000 die kriegt ein christian lindner
in einem vortrag ab sagt selbst opa
ramsauer macht noch an die 900.000 neben
er und vergisst dass gleich wieder
und was macht ihr denn den ganzen tag
auf dem sofa abhängen fürs klima also
los jetzt also hoch und beraterverträge
sich an oder aufsichtsratsposten
irgendwas mit anderen worten grüne geht
endlich mal arbeiten
echt jetzt peinlich die grünen verdienen
so wenig dazu man nennt sie schon
bündnis 90/die grünen
selbstverständlich können politiker noch
andere berufe haben wenn der bundestag
soll ja ein querschnitt der gesellschaft
sein
zur vermeidung von interessenskonflikten
durch nebenjobs braucht es aber
mindestens transparenz genau die hat vor
allem die union über jahre erfolgreich
verhindert weshalb warum musste erst so
ein masken skandal passieren allein
georg nüßlein als sowohl 660.000 euro an
der pandemie verdient alter tiefer kann
man nicht sinken
immerhin hat uns der schock darüber ein
neues abgeordnetengesetz beschert
demnächst müssen alle nebeneinkünfte ab
3000 euro im jahr auf heller und pfennig
angegeben werden
das hätten wir längst haben können sagt
auch dieser cdu mann wäre es schon sehr
recht gewesen wir hätten sehr viel
früher uns auf den weg gemacht
tatsächlich aber hat hans-georg von der
marwitz in den letzten jahren immer
wieder gegen vorschläge für mehr
transparenz gestimmt die aus anderen
fraktionen kamen ja meine nur weil man
prinzipiell für transparenz ist muss man
ja nicht gleich für transparenz stimmen
im bundestag er von der marwitz sitzt
übrigens im agrarausschuss in dem es von
abgeordneten die gleichzeitig
bauernvertreter sind nur so wimmelt das
stört hier auch kein die gute nachricht
politiker dürfen demnächst keine
bezahlten lobby jobs mehr annehmen die
schlechte was nüßlein löbel und hartmann
also die drei masken raffkes von der
union gemacht haben bleibt sehr
wahrscheinlich weiter straffrei und für
kontrolle und sanktionen wird es auch in
zukunft keine unabhängige kommission
geben das soll halt leider auch so
bleiben mit dem neuen gesetz dass der
bundestagspräsident alleine dafür
zuständig ist zu kontrollieren ob die
abgeordneten ihre angaben richtig machen
also im augenblick und so soll es auch
bleiben kontrolliert die politik sich
selbst ja ja ja es ist immer gut wenn
leute sich selber kontrollieren das hat
sich bewährt und wolfgang schäuble muss
man sagen ist ja vom fach der hat
schließlich auch mal 100.000 mark
gefunden
in seinem bundestagspräsidium sitzen
vertreter aller parteien und
kontrollieren die parteien das würde
erklären warum bis jetzt bei verstößen
meist nur sogenannte rügen ausgesprochen
wurden
rügen nicht mehr öffentliche wir reden
hier von internen geheimen rüben
abgeordnetenwatch hat schäuble deswegen
verklagt damit er die wenigstens
veröffentlicht aber er will nicht und im
keller des bundestags gibt es für die
geheimen rüben sogar einen geheimen raum
da muss der zu rügen de sein vergehen
zugeben und wenn er endlich alle
nebeneinkünfte korrekt nach gemeldet hat
dann wird er offiziell gerügt und zwar
mit dem traditionellen ritual das geht
so danach fahren alle zusammen nach
rügen sehr klar also etwas strengere
strafen dürften es in solchen fällen
schon sein finde ich tatsächlich hat
schäuble wohl nur einmal ein einziges
mal ein ordnungsgeld in höhe von 20.000
euro verhängt gegen die kürzlich
verstorbene cdu-abgeordnete karin strenz
die hatte einkünfte aus ihrer
lobbyarbeit für das land aserbaidschan
verschwiegen
sie wissen schon diese knuffige
autokratie geführt vom familien clan der
allofs und ich sag mal so von frau
strenz hat der clan echt was gekriegt
für sein geld im europarat in straßburg
wird 2015 gefordert politische gefangene
in aserbaidschan freizulassen
dagegen stimmt nur eine einzige
abgeordnete karin strenz ehrensache
sie konnte übrigens auch als
wahlbeobachter in keine auffälligkeiten
bei den wahlen in aserbaidschan
feststellen womit wir offiziell beim
thema korruption wären ja traut man uns
deutschen gar nicht zu aber wir können
das auch wenn wir wollen vor allem cdu
abgeordnete aus baden württemberg haben
so viel getan für aserbaidschan
man spricht schon scherzhaft von baku
württemberg baku hauptstadt von
aserbaidschan
reden wir drüber mit holger stockhaus er
sitzt für die cdu im auswärtigen
ausschuss herr stockhaus erklären sie
mir wie kann das passieren dass sich
gleich mehrere parteifreunde vor den
karren einer
im rhein autokratie spannen lassen ja
schade dass da immer gleich korruption
gewittert wird vielleicht ging es den
kollegen ja auch einfach um die deutsch
japanische freundschaft wunderbares
albanische sprichwort ein fremder ist
nur ein freund dem ich noch kein geld
geschenkt habe schauen sie mal steht
auch hier eingraviert in den goldenen
ring den ich von präsident alijew zu
ostern gekriegt habe wir sind immer so
schnell mit unseren urteilen herr welke
autokratie diktatur
der präsident hat seinen am 2003 ganz
demokratisch von seinem vater geerbt und
nur so bei der fußball-em finden bald
vier spiele in baku statt mal ernsthaft
dass eine diktatur wäre würde die uefa
dann spiele dahin vergeben guten
schlechtes beispiel ja das finde ich
auch aber würden sie mir nicht zustimmen
dass einige ihrer kollegen da doch ja
grenzen überschritten haben zb der viel
zu spät zurückgetretene herr hauptmann
aus thüringen in einer von hauptmann
herausgegebenen cdu zeitung kann man
einen anderen eindruck bekommen immer
wieder lobes artikel in südthüringen
kurier über baku gepard auch mal mit
einer anzeige für granatapfelsaft aus
dem südkaukasus
ja und es ist halt einer der besten
südkaukasischen granatapfel säfte auf
dem markt was ist denn daran werbung
fahren sie doch mal hin und bilden sie
ihr eigenes urteil
aserbaidschan
perle zwischen kaukasus und kaspischem
meer erleben sie unberührte natur wie
die einzigartige vulkanlandschaft von
bußtag oder tauchen sie ein in das
geschäftige treiben der quirligen
metropole backen können sie bitte sofort
damit aufhören werden sie mal lieber auf
mit ihren vorurteilen herr welke ja
aserbaidschan ist in der rangliste der
pressefreiheit nur auf platz 167 von 180
und es gibt ein paar ungeklärte
todesfälle in polizeigewahrsam
aber dafür werden frauen da ganz anders
gefördert als bei uns first lady und
vize-präsidentin der staatschef von
aserbaidschan alijew hat per dekret
seine ehefrau zu neuen vize-präsidenten
ernannt
den posten gab es vorher nicht ja da
gibt es nämlich keine gläserne decke
wenn ich in aserbaidschan richtig gut
aussehe und den präsidenten heiraten
kann ich alles werden also außer
präsident natürlich natürlich ich bin
immer noch fassungslos
fassungslos wer lässt sich von solchen
leuten kaufen
es geht doch gar nicht um aserbaidschan
heute kann es sich keiner mehr leisten
nur geschäfte mit lupenreinen demokraten
zu machen
wir müssen da insgesamt mal tolerant und
offener werden
deswegen sage ich warum immer nur
mallorca ryanair fliegt auch nach
weißrussland erleben sie den
zauberhaften juni in minsk ryanair
holger stockhaus
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye